American Horror Story is probably the most
terrifying, unsettling, brutally violent,
and bloody show on TV.
Here are some photos snapped on the sets of
the various seasons that should make for a
nice, calming visual salve after viewing even
the most disturbing episodes.
Cinematic Satan-worshippers may be all about
bringing the reign of pure evil to Earth,
but they also enjoy a certain level of fanciness.
In American Horror Story: Apocalypse, the
wicked leaders of Outpost 3 hold a handful
of survivors essentially captive, but still
make sure they dress in nice clothes, drink
out of nice goblets, and enjoy the occasional
celebratory banquet or high-end party.
It's just nice to be fancy, even after the
end of the world.
Leslie Grossman, along with other members
of the Apocalypse cast, had apparently spent
a few too many hours filming one of these
party sequences.
With costars Joan Collins and Evan Peters
looking on in amusement, Grossman got so punch
drunk and silly that she and her blonde fright
wig took a faceplant on the fine china.
Denis O'Hare disappears into his roles.
He's clearly one of those actors who does
everything he can to learn everything about
a character, both inside and out.
He's played many memorable parts in several
American Horror Story iterations, including
severely burned philanderer Larry Harvey in
Murder House, mute witch school servant Spalding
in Coven, and on Hotel, a transgender hotel
clerk with a heartbreaking backstory named
Liz Taylor.
Having lived as a Kansas salesman who secretly
wore women's clothing on business trips, a
visit to the Hotel Cortez and a meeting with
Elizabeth inspired Liz to be true to herself
and take a stint working at the haunted hotel.
"You see everything when the world doesn't
see you."
Not only did O'Hare have to dig deep to find
the motivations and executions for his complex
character, he had to prepare his body, too.
He endured extensive makeup to get that bald
head and heavily made-up look, as well as
regular facial hair trim sessions.
Here he is preparing for a shooting day.
Obviously, recurring American Horror Story
cast member and frequent Emmy nominee Sarah
Paulson doesn't have two heads in real life
which means the effects wizards behind American
Horror Story: Freak Show had their work cut
out for them.
In order for Paulson to play Bette and Dot
Tattler, two heads with unique personalities
who shared a body, it required a lot of special
effects, digital manipulation, and time.
"We could have such a fantastic time singin'
and dancin' on our own tv show."
First, the crew took a mold of Paulson's real
head and used it to build a prosthetic head
that bears a striking resemblance to the actress.
The head was then positioned differently,
depending on if Paulson was filming her lines
as Bette or Dot.
Scenes took as long as 15 hours to shoot,
and then the footage went to the computers
to make the idea of a double Sarah Paulson
seem visually convincing.
One of the most memorable and striking characters
in American Horror Story will always be Pepper,
who appears in both the Asylum and Freak Show
seasons, first as an institutionalized patient
and then as a performer in an unsettling traveling
sideshow.
There's been no shortage of stunning transformations
among the AHS cast, but Naomi Grossman is
almost completely unrecognizable when she's
not in her Pepper guise.
That's because becoming the character involves
an elaborate physical transformation that
was well-documented.
In addition to three hours in a makeup chair
for every day she was needed on set, Grossman's
preparation required fake teeth, a single
contact lens that both distorted her vision
and altered the appearance of her eye, as
well as a unique hairdo.
For that, Grossman had to shave off most of
her hair which was step one in her precise
and perfect Pepper preparations.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.